money in this morning's money watch
we're focusing on the start of tax
season oh gosh here we go the IRS has
been accepting and processing 2022 tax
year returns more than 168 million
individual tax returns are expected to
be filed this year with the deadline set
for April 18th taxpayers will have three
extra days to file CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here she's
the author of a new book this is for you
America the great money reset change
your work change your wealth change your
life I love the title Jill she joins us
now at the table good morning good
morning before you get started I'm still
reflecting on Tony's story because you
were talking about the guys that are
staying at home watching TV can you
imagine Jill if you were working all day
long you come home and your partner is
sitting in front of the TV playing a
video game or watching TVs no maybe they
can be very irritated I would too and
I'm hoping that maybe they're the ones
who start compiling the tax information
for the family maybe they need your book
yeah exactly right change your work a
challenger so I'm already a little
nervous about taxes because I've been
told my record keeping is not good oh
dear yep I may be calling you later
they're not watching
so like what can people expect so this
year's going to be an interesting year
because it's kind of back to the back to
where we were in 2019 pre-pandemic so as
you mentioned we've got three extra days
this is because of the emancipation day
holiday in Washington D.C so you get
those three extra days but what some
people will need the 3x yeah I think so
but you know what's really fascinating
to me is that when you go back to 2019
you go back to all the things that we
had then are really exactly the same so
there are no extra stimulus payments
unemployment benefits are taxable again
you do not get an enhanced child tax
credit so you might want to pull out
your 2019 return as a way yeah just to
look as a guidepost for what's it going
to be like this year I always pay my
taxes I just won't be on the record I've
never not paid my taxes but the IRS is
warning that refunds are going to be
smaller this year for most people why is
that well when you look at all those
programs they put a lot of extra money
in our pockets and so when you look at
the average refund last year it was
about just under thirty two hundred
dollars wow it's probably going to go
back down to say 2 800 again because
those programs are gone by the way
remember twenty eight hundred dollars is
a lot of money and I'd prefer that you
kept that money throughout the year not
lend it to Uncle Sam with an
interest-free loan but that being said
you're likely to get a smaller refund
now remember the fastest way to get your
refund is to file electronically and
choose direct deposit if you do that you
are likely to get your refund within 21
days for some reason that's Speedy 21
days well 21 days
electronically for years and it's great
but when it comes to electronic filing I
do worry about websites that are not
what they say they are and people
getting misled so for free filing
resources they want to file
electronically where do they go okay
this is an underused resource at the IRS
it's called IRS free file and if you've
got income of less than 73 000 that's a
lot of money for most Americans most
households yes indeed and you can have
the IRS free file system it's the forms
but they'll also pair you with one of
these excuse me tax preparation
companies huge now second thing I want
to remind people there's something
called the volunteer income tax
assistance or Vita program if you have
income below a certain level it is
available to you this is for what is the
level 58
000 a 60 000 sorry sixty thousand
dollars and this is available to people
who are maybe non-english speakers they
are people with disabilities and if you
really need help this is a wonderful
organization and finally there's tax
counseling for the elderly this is great
if you're over 60 which by the way
elderly that's a little bit of a reach
for me but it's if you're over the age
of 60 there are people who will hold
your hand and they have a specialty in
things that impact you Social Security
benefits their uh retirement benefits
things that are really focused on people
in retirement we've been focusing a lot
on the gig economy especially in the
wake of the pandemic so for people who
are getting paid by venmo or by Zell or
PayPal what do they need to know so
there was supposed to be a rule that
went into place this year it's on Ice
it's not happening that rule was that if
you made more than 600 bucks
regardless of the number of transactions
on any of these digital payment
platforms you had to report to the IRS
that's not happening this year but if
you're a gig worker get ready that is
coming in the future and if you make
more than twenty thousand dollars with
more than 200 transactions you do have
to report something that's always
controversial because a lot of people
working from home uh can you deduct your
home office well if you are an employee
you cannot because this is the 2017 tax
law change so if you are a W-2 employee
no deductions if you're self-employed
and you know you use your house and
that's the main place that you do your
work absolutely but you have to be
self-employed Gail get your records
together girl yeah I know I'm becoming
I'm going to call you all right I'll
read the book
yes
thank you Jill thanks